en el corazón de la ciudad vieja de van
los jordanos se han mantenido al tanto
de la actualidad de su país comprando
periódicos en este quiosco pero hoy por
hoy los titulares ya no sorprenden a los
lectores
la calidad de los medios de comunicación
jordanos se ha deteriorado en los
últimos años hay temas de lo que no está
permitido hablar
la lista de los temas censurados es
establecida por los tribunales entre
estos temas censurados está no solo
cualquier crítica a la familia real sino
también los casos de corrupción las
protestas o los feminicidios
en los suburbios de amán el periodista
baselocori intenta luchar contra estas
medidas liberticidas
no comprometer la información Ese es
nuestro lema
es fundador de una de las pocas páginas
web de noticias independientes del país
fue detenido en 2020 mientras cubría una
huelga de profesores
las autoridades también suelen registrar
su oficina y ponerle multas
todos los días uno sabe que puede ser
blanco de una de las herramientas de
represión que el gobierno utiliza para
restringir la libertad de prensa
a pesar de las amenazas sigue
investigando un tema delicado con malek
uno de sus periodistas de confianza
Queremos saber más sobre los casos de
presos políticos
tenemos que sacar a la luz las
violaciones de los derechos humanos de
la libertad e incluso de la Constitución
y malek podrían ser condenados a tres
meses de cárcel si su trabajo es
considerado demasiado polémico una de
las pocas organizaciones locales que los
defiende es el sindicato de periodistas
Ibrahim cavilat apoya a decenas de
colegas que están siendo perseguidos en
nombre de leyes que deberían estar
dirigidas a luchar contra
ciberdelincuencia o el terrorismo
todas estas leyes son interpretadas muy
ampliamente para permitir que los
tribunales silencien a los periodistas y
por extensión a toda la sociedad
el sindicalista teme que la autocensura
se vuelva la norma para su profesión
internet también es vigilado de cerca
pero en las redes sociales algunos aún
encuentran un espacio de libertad
un colectivo Regional de caricaturistas
que se formó en 2013 tras la primavera
árabe sus caricaturas son un éxito en
internet
cuando empezaron las revoluciones y las
primaveras árabes los regímenes
prometieron reformas pero no hubo
ninguna reforma ni lucha contra la
corrupción
es recordarle a la gente que lo que ha
ocurrido en los últimos 11 o 12 años
no ha terminado el reino Hache mío ocupa
actualmente el puesto 120 entre 180
países en la clasificación Mundial de la
libertad de prensa
France 24 contactó a las autoridades
jordanas Pero estas se negaron a
responder a nuestras preguntas